salut aujourd'hui on est samedi c'est le
jour du master class aujourd'hui je vous
donne une technique une vraie technique
permet de retenir un jeu de cartes dans
l'ordre vous allez donc pouvoir retenir
52 cartes dans un ordre complètement
aléatoire mélangés par quelqu'un vous
allez faire ce truc de ouf
ce sera pas le master class le plus long
en fait à vous expliquer par contre ça
va peut être être un des plus longs à
mettre en place pour vous à travailler
c'est assez long à faire mais après
c'est un petit peu comme la table de
rappel c'est au bénéfice de toute une
vie pour ça on va utiliser le système
pea op comme personnage a comme action
est haut comme objet l'idée est très
simple c'est la plus simple du monde il
faut attribuer à chacune des 52 cartes
d'un jeu un personnage
une action est un objet un petit peu
comme la table de rappel avec laquelle
vous codifié un nombre ou un chiffre par
une image là vous allez codé chaque
carte par trois données par le nom d'un
personnage donc la visualisation d'un
personnage la visualisation d'une action
et la visualisation d'un abri exemple
personnel avec l'as de pique l'as de
pique pour moi en personne c'est maurice
parce que j'ai un ami qui s'appelle
maurice et qu'un tatouage de l'as de
pique sur le bras en action l'action
l'action de l'as de pique pour moi c'est
sucer ah oui forcément je sais à quoi
vous pensez
je suis mentaliste comme sucer son doigt
ou terrible que ça et l'objet c'est la
tour eiffel donc pour moi cette carte
c'est maurice qui suce la tour eiffel en
fait une miniature et j'ai ce genre de
chose de coder pour les 52 cartes de mon
jeu si je prends le set de carreaux pour
moi le site de carros et james bond pour
le personnage parce que 007 s'étirer
pour l'action tiré au fusil au revolver
est l'objet sont des fenêtres
donc c'est james bond qui tire au
revolver dans des fenêtres etc etc pour
toutes les cartes c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus longs à mettre en place mais une
fois que vous maîtrisez les deux les
trois données pour les 52 cartes ça
permet de retenir le jeu de cartes
beaucoup plus vite
par groupes de trois et pour retenir un
groupe de trois vous allez prendre le
personnage pour la première carte
l'action de la deuxième carte est
l'objet de la troisième carte ça peut
vous faire instantanément une petite
saynète comme on avait fait par exemple
pour pour les numéros de téléphone et ça
se tiendra immédiatement si par exemple
je retourne le roi de 13 pour moi c'est
d'alissa c'est le peintre dali autant le
set de carreaux vous savez c'est tiré
revolver et l'as de pique c'est la tour
eiffel et bella instantanément je vois
ta vie avec un gros pistolet à plomb que
je peux pourquoi en train de tirer dans
la tour eiffel et d'alice est roi de
trèfle tirer ses sept de carreaux tour
eiffel c'est l'as de pique c'est des
choses que je peux pas oublier parce que
c'est ça que j'ai travaillé au préalable
au lieu de retenir 52 cartes différentes
une grosse masse de choses à retenir
vous allez revenir 17 petites saynètes
et une ou deux cartes en plus mais vous
allez retenir beaucoup moins de choses
du coup et c'est tout l'intérêt
d'utiliser le système pos pour ça c'est
d'avoir le sentiment qu'on a moins de
choses à apprendre
et en plus on n'apprend pas parce
qu'encore une fois on crée des souvenirs
avec des images vous pouvez haut-gradé
la difficulté si jamais vous trouvez ça
trop simple c'est de revenir en fait la
position de la carte dans le jeu
quelques cartons 17 quelle carte et en
52 quelle carte et en 20e position
chacun a sa méthode pour ça moi
j'utilise les images de la table de
rappelle donc que je vous avais expliqué
sur un sur un des premiers masters class
je prends en fond de décor de chaque
saynète une de mes images clés de la
table de rappel donc pour le premier
groupe de trois personnages action objet
je m en fond de décor une forêt de
sapins parce que vous vous souvenez
peut-être mais pour moi le 1 c'est le
sapin qu'à chaque fois que je recommence
à un groupe de trois donc que je suis un
personnage je rajoute vraiment en fond
de décor de la saynète mon image de ma
table de rappel comme ça tous les trois
ce qui fait que si on me demande quelle
carte est en position numéro 26 par
exemple je fais 26 / 3 de ma tête donc
ça fait 8,6 ça veut dire que c'est
l'objet de mon groupe de vite je vais
aller de ma tête aux comprimés roses 8
donc je vais souvent dans un parc à
huîtres ou ton amer puisque pour moi en
huit g8 re dedans ma table de rappel je
vais avoir le personnage action objets
et je sais que c'est l'objet en fait le
numéro 26 à cet endroit là est-ce que
c'est clair pour un samedi matin savais
que je fais cette vidéo très tôt un
d'ailleurs il est il est 8h 50 2
je sais pas si à 8h52 je suis très clair
en fait le concept du système perron est
assez simple je crois expliqué à
comprendre
après tout la difficulté c'est de
travailler ça pour chaque carte chez un
ami benoît heureusement qui est
spécialiste de la mémoire qui lui a
rajouté aussi les émotions il a racheté
d'autres choses peux pas trop vous en
parler de ça ça lui appartient mais on
peut aller encore plus loin dans le
concept en fait pour revenir l'écart par
groupes de 5 2 6 voire même plus
déjà quand on les retient par groupes de
cinq se dire qu'on a plus de dix
éléments à retenir pour un jeu de 52
cartes donc on peut commencer à
envisager le double jeu de 52 cartes
hier les 104 car j'aurais dû appeler
cette chaîne amusons-nous avec notre
cerveau au niveau de la méthodologie je
vous conseille tout d'abord de prendre
le temps sur une feuille décrire les 52
car dans un tableau en fait est de
mettre en place le nom de chaque
personnage de chaque action de chaque
objet qui correspond à chaque carte
trouvez vous des astuces également d
astuce mnémotechnique en fait pour
pouvoir toujours y revenir par exemple
pour moi l'objet de tous les as sont des
monuments historiques
les personnes de tous les as ce sont des
amis à moi qui sont magicien les actions
toutes les cartes commence par là même
première lettre que mon image dans ma
table de rappel par exemple dans ma
table de rappel cette ces têtes et vous
avez vu pour le set de caro s'était tiré
et pour le set de coeur cette route et
pour le set de 13,7 ordre voilà comme ça
je me trouve une logique
j'ai plein de logique comme ça qui sont
croisés en fonction de la famille en
fonction du chiffre
je m'en sers moi aujourd'hui mais ça m'a
beaucoup aidé à retenir ça au départ et
puis ça m'aide également quand je me
resserre du système perreault que ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai pas fait je
me fais confiance j'ai pas peur d'avoir
un bug et à un moment donné
en passant la carte et après quand vous
vous entraînerez bête voulait passerait
comme ça lentement une à une devant joue
en créant vos saynètes par 3 en prenant
le temps comme ça
au départ vous irez très lentement c'est
normal il faut aller lentement pour
commencer est de plus en plus rapidement
et après ça deviendra facile
voilà c'était les bases du système p o
comme je vous l'aï dit c'était pas le
masters casse le plus long à vous
expliquer par contre c'est sûrement un
des plus longs à mettre en place voire
même de tout ce que vous avez fait c'est
le plus long à mettre en place un je
suis persuadé n'hésitez pas à séquencer
en fait votre masse de travail si vous
voulez apprendre à faire ça si vous
voulez apprendre à retenir un jeu de
cartes
c'est à dire que amusez-vous à faire
déjà ça sur les treize cartes à pic
donc vous trouvez personne ajaccio
obligé pour les treize cartes de pique
et vous mélangez en fait les treize
cartes à pic et vous essayez de les
retenir dans l'ordre même si ça peut
vous paraît simple comme ça fait le père
famille en fait un groupe de treize celi
train d'essayer de tout faire d'un coup
et est d'aller à l'échec
déjà vous allez voir qu'elle crée ce
carton commence à s'amuser une fois que
vous maîtrisez bien tous les
nick vous passez au carreau après vous
faites affaire très au fait les choeurs
et après vous faites tout j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plus vraiment si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas vous pouvez
vous abonner pour pas rater les
prochaines vidéos et ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir vous pouvez aussi
commenté si vous avez des questions à me
poser
vous pouvez venir voir les
hallucinations collectives et autres
illusions d'optique le 28 mars la
prochaine et puis moi je suis en
spectacle avec fabien une carte vous
mentalise les prochaines dates sont à
mulhouse début avril à l'entrepôt
théâtre et si vous venez on se fait une
petite vidéo à la fin en plus si tout va
bien on devrait passer la barre des 2000
abonnés ce week-end je voulais vous dire
un gros merci par rapport à ça un très
très gros merci j'avais un objectif à
2500 abonnés pour faire un live avec
vous un espèce de live apéro et au
départ c'était de l'ordre du fantasme et
puis je vois qu'on y arrive en fait on
va y arriver je pensais pour y arriver
encore plus vite vous pouvez partager la
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
parler aux gens que ça peut intéresser
il ya beaucoup d'astuces ils allaient
mentalisation des copains il ya les
explications du dimanche ça je sais que
vous aimez bien mais que vous aimez bien
aussi le garder pour vous et d'ailleurs
la prochaine explications dimanche bas
ce sera demain alors rendez vous demain
à 11 heures pour le prochain mandat les
blogs charles